DAVE GAGEOT: With almost
500 sessions on Next 2019,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
"Kubernetes and VS Code--
Zero to Deployed,"
then stay tuned,
because here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what is it like to be a
developer in a Kubernetes
world?
Well, we've asked
developers, and they told us
it's frustrating.
There's too much configuration.
Debugging is a pain.
Application now have
so many moving parts.
Developers simply want to
spend more time in their code.
At Next, we've introduced Cloud
Code, a set of integrated tools
that help you remove the
complexity out of Kubernetes
and spend more
time on your code.
Today, I'm going to show
you Cloud Code for VS Code.
The first feature that
comes with Cloud Code
is a visual cluster explorer.
Most of the things you would do
with the kubectl command line
you can do more easily
with a graphical interface.
You can browse the
[? workflows, ?] list the pods
and containers, you
can stream the logs,
or get a terminal inside a
running container with just
a few clicks.
One can also create a cluster.
And because we want
Cloud Code to be open,
we support multiple
cloud providers.
You can use Cloud Code
on-prem, in the cloud,
or on your desktop.
Creating a cluster
on GKE is so simple.
With just a few clicks, I
start a multinode cluster
on Google Cloud.
I can even install
Istio or Cloud Run
just by ticking a box.
It's very useful for developers.
Another feature that
Cloud Code brings
is robust samples to
help you get started.
No matter the language,
you can say bye
to the empty page syndrome.
Here, for example, I'm going
to create a Go Hello World
example.
Each sample comes
with source code,
Dockerfiles,
Kubernetes manifest--
everything is preconfigured to
easily get started and learn.
Cloud Code also provides
full documentation
for Kubernetes manifest.
You get tool tips,
completion, validation--
everything you need to write
those YAML files more easily.
With Cloud Code,
it's also super easy
to deploy my code to
a Kubernetes cluster.
I just have to hit
Cloud Code Deploy
and the IDE will tell
me when it's done,
and it should give me the URL
to connect to my application.
It's so easy.
An even more powerful mode is
to use Cloud Code Continuously
Deploy.
It will redeploy my application
automatically each time
I make a change.
I change the code, save,
and boom, it's deployed.
This way, I can really
just focus on my code
and see the results
very quickly.
Now, let me show you how to use
Cloud Code on a more advanced
project.
It's a guest book project
that I've just started.
It's not fully done yet.
I've got the source code and
some of the YAML manifests,
but not all of them.
I'm going to use
another powerful feature
of Cloud Code, which is
YAML Manifest Templates.
It's super convenient
for beginners.
Once again, it helps you avoid
starting from a blank page.
OK.
I'm going to finish
those YAML files
and deploy my application with
Cloud Code Continuously Deploy.
See, the IDE tells me when
everything is up and running.
OK, but my
application has a bug.
So let's talk about debugging--
a major pain point
with Kubernetes.
When your application
has a bug, you'd
like to know what's going on.
And it's really not that
easy with Kubernetes.
You have to connect
to remote container.
Not easy.
With Cloud Code, I can
use the tools I'm used to
and hit Debug in
VS Code and boom.
Debug is automatically
configured
to connect to the container,
and I can see what's going on.
I can add breakpoints.
I can see variables.
I can even fix the bug,
and the application
is automatically redeployed.
It's almost magical.
To sum up, we've seen how to
get started from code samples.
We've seen how to create
and explore remote clusters.
And finally, we've seen how
easy it is to deploy and debug
our application.
So how do you get Cloud Code?
Just get it installed
from the marketplace,
either on VS Code or IntelliJ.
It's that simple.
If you'd like to see the full
talk, check out the link below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]